because the organization the agenda
whether you like it on is communist
that's that's what it is the movement is
about identity politics hmm and the
cause anti racism well we should all be
anti-racist hello welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster i'm
konstantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is a conservative youtuber
maya 2z welcome to trigonometry
thank you much thanks for having me it's
good to have you on the show man you've
been doing some great work in the last
few weeks and we're delighted to have
you on but for anyone who doesn't know
who you are what you do just give us a
background you've obviously got an
interesting back story as well tell us
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey that brings
you to this very uncomfortable chair
right yeah yeah usually people say
conservative you too because it's easier
obviously to say that but I'm longer my
definition is I'm more of a classical
liberal conservative YouTube or
libertarian leaning conservative it's
very long complicated because I think it
goes back to my background so I was
actually for those who don't know I was
born in Iran I came here as a kid my
mother was a political refugee I came to
the west obviously our freedom and I
grew up on a council estate in Lucien
kind of like a typical working-class
London life and you downgraded yeah yeah
yeah that was our the first culture
shock the second shock was the fact that
I came here I thought people in the West
will be very proactive positive you know
because I have more freedom it the area
I was living in in southeast London
everybody was grumpy everyone was saying
he's the worst country ever and it was
just unhappy and I was like well this is
not working it is something wrong cuz
you know I was seeing the good things
and didn't think of it as the perfect
thing but you know things were going
well at least we had we were free to
leave the house without dinner being
worried about the police sure this is no
issue lockdown has brought back some
nostalgia yeah I was actually on the
tube earlier
everybody has to wear masks and but
people are just having their masks like
hanging around our neck and then if they
see an inspector they put it back on
it's just like in Iran because head
scarves are mandatory so women just like
leave him hanging when they say police
offer they just put it back on same
thing but yeah so obviously came here
went to university studied finance and
then I realized I don't want to work in
finance it's too boring and so worked in
Parliament then I realized I don't
actually want to work in policy in
politics because it's also boring and
money's terrible but I was political
because of my background so then I just
had normal jobs I did in a pizza shop
and everything then I started YouTube as
a hobby and this was the moment when the
Iranian regime decided to ban me from
entering Iran because apparently I am
now an mi6 Tory agent if you didn't know
so if I go you know being very common
you're putting your [ __ ] on YouTube and
I was watching it what's the new
training we've got his double bluff yeah
we've had some budget cousin my face I
got angry so I went on YouTube our face
we've made videos and started ranting
you know my friends were like just make
more videos so I made with videos and
then brexit happen and then that's when
I peaked and now that's where I am and
you peak because you you were progrexion
yes so obviously after the 2016
referendum I campaigned for vote leave
and we thought that's it
victory done let's move on then two
years later was still stuck so this is
around 2018 2019 or the end of 2018 when
that's when I started doing the YouTube
videos again because of brexit and how
Theresa May was a terrible manager as a
leader and that's when a lot of my
audience were created because they were
sick and tired of the mainstream media
they didn't get proper information or
update and brexit because they were just
repeating the same things so I was
trying to give them some more
information about like was actually
happening and what I've always been
doing with my channel is I'm always open
and honest about my leanings and so that
I don't pretend to be completely
impartial but I always try my best to
say I'm being objected these are the
facts this is my opinion on this fact
but you decide for yourself do your own
research whatever you want to do so I
think that's what people like and why is
it that you have the sort of
conservative
is there a specific moment or is it kind
of a evolutionary thing why are you so
evil it's not evil it's a problematic
that's what yeah I love that word I
think it's for a lot of people I know
especially younger conservative leaning
people usually you meet some people who
are who we're left-wing or born into a
socialist family and they had an
awakening a red pill moment so some
people just born into a conservative
family for me it's kind of neither it's
a it was gradual hmm but they're not
deep down I realize it's just it was
always in me genetically I'm also
upbringing and everything and I'm
culturally conservative and so when
people ask well how you left or right
because it's quite vague I would say
culturally and conservative so I believe
in Flags order family and economically
that's when my strength is I'm free
market capitalism I'm basically
believing almost no control you know you
could compromise on a very very tiny
safety net to make sure that people are
still detected and socially I'm a
libertarian so I believe it you should
be able to do whatever you want as long
as you don't harm anybody else and and I
think it's just been always in me and I
think because of my upbringing in Iran
and we were told you know allowed to do
certain things he just want to be free I
think that's how it was created and you
think we take it we don't how can I put
it appreciate freedom in this country
yeah we're taken for granted massively
it's it's a cliche we've always been
talking about this for years and decades
and everybody intellectuals from left
and right and and we know we could
always talk about like 1984 the book and
everything but it is reality because and
also not only that people are not
grateful for the freedoms they have but
they're also not interested in politics
but that could be a good thing so in the
West when things are relatively well in
a society things are generally good
you're safe you have a job you have
family and people aren't interested in
politics they also don't go out to vote
properly
whereas in in countries like Iran or the
countries up Oh kind of like Russia when
they have elections people even know
that those votes then we'd account its
still queue for hours to me even though
they know is rigged but it's because you
know they that's the value that they did
and but in the West EAB taken for
granted then I think if we're not
careful I mean I'm not one of those
pessimistic people but over the last few
decades not just yet
especially they woke stuff right now is
it joke but eventually it could get
serious and you know we could shoot
ourselves in the foot it's a really
interesting point you make about
appreciating the opportunity and I
suspect is probably a symbol of how
successful the West has been in creating
a stable society because you talk about
Russia and Ron and all of these place
norisse notions
yes exactly fantastic places to live but
you know in those places the outcome of
an election has the potential to
radically transform society in other
words if you have one person two
candidates one of them will create a
society that looks nothing like the
other one right and that's why people
feel so strongly and passionately about
the right to vote in this country vote
laboratory yeah almost lecture doesn't
nothing nothing will change and I think
that's probably a big part of why people
can become quite apathetic is it's a
measure of how successful we've been
isn't it yeah and this is the problem
I've even struggled with this because on
the one hand so the British democracy is
not full democracy that's the whole
point of the system the constitutional
monarchy in the head of state that we
have is there to keep everything stable
it's there to have the Tories and Labour
be center left and centre right
basically boring not much will change
regardless of how you vote so that's the
objective which is fine well I have a
problem with that because then you
create an establishment but there's very
complacent they make the wrong decisions
and ideally you want a more radical kind
of radical options but then that's also
kind of drastic because you know you
could eventually take me vote for a
communist or like cool bin or whatever
it is a big bit of a risk but I feel
like I'm one of those my politics
forward my audiologist I'm a humanoid I
do believe in and trust humans even if
they make mistakes they kind of have to
make the mistake to realise what it is
and so the I think I'm more than I'm
prefer to have radical options and just
complacency and I mean well there was a
radical option at one point in the last
general election which was a brexit
party wasn't it which obviously is now
defunct but at the time it was right
option for a lot particularly for
working-class people who felt
disenfranchised yeah I mean you would
say you could say the brexit party was
the most radical option for example but
only in a sense that it was more of a
wave hmm not policy-wise nine tons of
policy there was it was the whole kind
of ant establishment sort of mentality
and so you know it's not necessarily
that radical in that sense but as we
just said it's because when the
political system becomes so centralized
and complacent and they'll look the same
sound the same walk the same if someone
something like the brakes of party comes
up for the British culture that's like
radical the brexit party for the rest of
the world of Europe that's like tiny and
like in a moderate that like very nice
they didn't say anything too bad there's
anything that crazy and more than one of
the controversial policies was to scrap
HST which I believe it yeah and one of
the interesting things to me you talk
about you know you believe in borders
you so you basically agree with the
people who created top and chairs they
there's something you believe in borders
all of a sudden right yeah but it always
boggles my mind that people think that's
like a controversial idea because
actually a lot of first-generation
immigrants like us who came here under
the existing legal system don't support
people who come here legally or a very
large numbers because we recognize that
you know people need to come here they
need to integrate they need to become
part of society they need to learn the
language and when you get a mass wave of
immigration that sometimes prevents that
from happening and it's not a criticism
of those people or rejection of them
it's just a recognizing human reality
isn't it yeah and then we get cold that
we're taking away the ladder that we use
it's not the case it's in reality the
way I see politics
I know people use that example Margaret
Thatcher saying like economics like
fiscal conservatism is basically a good
housekeeping but politics I always also
see it just like how you see your
personal life just life in general and a
basic level you have a home and the
house has a door and walls and ceiling
that's your country as well that's
that's your tribe because people are
tribal and tribe starts from home and
then the neighborhood and then your
social circle of friends and then your
city and then your country and then your
planet that's just how it is
and when we say for example
first generation migrants when they are
we're the second generation when they
talk about borders people on the Left
say well that means you are now fascist
or you're basically you're pandering to
the people who hate you secretly listen
no one said close down the borders and
this is why you're gonna set like Chad's
and all these like lefties who are being
exposed because the hypocrisy is that
well two days ago they were saying that
both in America Trump and in the UK
we've had police funding in the budget
how dare you crimes going up then two
minutes later is that defund the police
pick a side guys and yes it's a weird
situation and why do you think the term
patriotic has become such a dirty word
for it's particularly people on the Left
because you know we I was born here you
came here solely Constantine it's a
great contrary I have important majority
countries it's one of the best why is it
bad to be proud to be British it is a
very and the most countries in the West
are having this problem but it
specifically a British problem and
because in America if he ignore the last
four years of Trump because even even
right now even Democrats are patriotic
they use the flag and everything and
putting aside Germany because that's a
very exceptional even in France and all
the countries that Netherlands they are
very patriotic yeah well they're also
very liberal and they're very obviously
like in a euro file but they are very
patriotic it's a very British problem
because of the culture because the Brits
seems to days of anglo-saxons and then
obviously you had the kings in England
and then the British Empire the whole
concept of the British nurse saw the the
Englishness other time was simply to
just get out there
explore the world which was to expand
and then obviously the Empire came and
then trade across the world so and then
now the Commonwealth which is the same
thing
they jump to the next step like forget
about just patriotism for the kre-o
country don't say ignore it but we could
now just be internationalist and then
now that that's all over a lot of people
struggle to defend British values so if
you like ask a generic Politico and
usually get it from like Lib Dems of
Labor will get the worst British and
they say oh like tolerance what on earth
is tolerance like I don't
people who think that tolerance is a
good idea it over like acceptance that's
bad
I mean first it's good lazing like it
should be there because you know if you
say something like you know idiotic that
I don't like
don't you pointed at me I was just about
to say but I should tolerate it accepted
but that's you know you're still free
speech it's also my right to just
tolerate you not to be bad against you
because that's what that's what you
believe
tolerance is fine but when people use it
as a triumph over acceptance and because
I think what they mean is we're
welcoming and accepting but they say
tolerance and so your British has had
struggled in terms of defending the
values that we have and that's why even
I sometimes struggle so I always try to
differentiate between patriotism and
nationalism and also globalism and
internationalism so in my view
internationally means that obviously you
still believe in free trade and you know
cooperating with your allies well
globalism in a sense that you believe in
international bodies and any another
United States of Europe running your
country and other countries
yeah I'm against that right this is
about working together with other
nations as opposed to eroding national
identity exactly never surrender you
just think I know I'm curious to ask you
this question because I remember a
couple years ago making a very similar
point to a comedian may even been a
friend of mine and I remember saying to
him well I think it's important that we
recognize that Britain has a certain set
of values and like you know there's such
a thing as British values and with
yesterda and he was like what are you
talking about this is such things
British rallies and I'm going like how
can this I don't you can't survive it as
a civilization if you don't have any
sense of what your values are can you
know you do need to be self-aware and
it's not I mean we did criticize the
whole that the struggle with the British
values a lot of people have heard that
people in France and other countries
also have that struggle you know I was
talking to this Hallion friend he was
thinking that their values are just
basically it getting rid of the Roman
Empire so what did you do it also like
you know food like I don't think food is
your values but it definitely is me oh
yeah the way you deal with it and its
language and everything but I think when
it comes to British values
it's a lot easier to defend or explain
what they are because they are out there
so you know it's more visible not
visible in that sense but like you have
the modern structural democracy it came
from here the values of free trade came
from here because they had to get out
there as I said they had to go explore
and the the modern version of justice in
terms of the law and order came from
here and there's a lot of I mean and you
could then talk about all the trivial
stuff and they're gonna move to what
food earlier with you like Italy but you
know having language humor like all the
things that they know how you are with
your neighbors the attitude the whole
self-replicating stuff the whole kind of
people light even if you want to be like
in a very direct and say I hate you and
I keep okay I hate but you know just be
more civil and be more civilized these
are values and why do you think that we
can't embrace and love the fact that
we're British and it's seen as a dirty
as a dirty thing in this country we've
been brainwashed using our education
system for decades and the only history
that we actually learn in this country
apart from like the ancient times is
just about the Greeks in the Roman a
couple of things but no one person no
one talks about the Persian Empire the
first Empire it's very selective the way
history is taught they need a skip from
the ancient times they skipped most of
it and they come closer to basically
after the like 1500s 1600s and then the
Empire and then so what all you see and
you're all you're taught is the bad
things that come across as bad like you
know oh yeah but it's the moment when
the West became powerful so the West in
history books have always been seen as
superior and now we have to feel guilty
about it because it's now our fault and
they forget about something but there
was a time when dude Europe and Western
Europe was just full of like villages
and people who were just eating with
their hands and he was the Mid East and
East that then who had civilization and
you know not just an architectural
mathematics all invented by those Muslim
empires that occupy that space really
you're right we don't we don't never get
taught about it I'm not sure if they're
having a conversation about slavery in
the Muslim world at the moment we had a
little bit of that I've heard so we seem
to be taking a very one-sided approach
into history is what you're saying
really yeah and well speaking of all
that stuff in history you've you've done
some reporting if you like because what
you really tried to do I think more
recently is to look at what's actually
happening on the ground and and present
because I think you're right a lot of
people don't trust the mentoring media
anymore and we've seen it over the last
couple of weeks obviously was laughed
and mocked to death the largely peaceful
protests which injured 27 police yes
all of that stuff so you actually
covered that the BLM protests in London
tell us a bit about that yeah so firstly
I got there slightly later that both
sides were divided I accidentally BLM
site as I was walking well you you fear
man visually but my short just explain
about where it was watch City yes
essentially there was a massive protest
in Westminster in central London okay
Parliament this was a day when there was
supposed to be counter protests against
BLM so the people who were trying to
defend the statues mm-hmm and that was a
coalition of various groups and so you
just had some random people like you
know just like ordinary people and you
had some you know veteran groups you had
your typical football lads and you did
have a small group of you know actual
crazies and just like causing chaos in
the morning but they left and but the
media only talked about them say know
that they're all basically far-right or
whatever and then you still had the
black lives matter slash and Tifa and
and even in that group you still had a
lot of random kids you know just being
dragged there because they thought it's
a good cause obviously they didn't they
don't know much about the organization
and but then primarily you had massive
activists who been doing this for years
they used to it's like young German
Corbin for example you know they love
that sort of stuff but I was there and
the mainstream media where even the
police were very it was very interesting
and the police on the balaam side there
was a massive divide you had your
typical standard community support
police officers genuinely and then you
have the other side you had this like
Dwyer squad yeah and and again
surprisingly Oh
unsurprisingly most the violence
actually came from the other side and
I'm not even defending in this fight
when I'm just being objective and
because you know that anti BLM side
let's just say they did cause some chaos
beginning there were randomly as I can
the police for some reason and and but
we've seen the pictures we've seen the
videos also the reports from hospitals
all the people who got attacked were
attacked by the BLM site or an Tifa side
and but it wasn't really reported and so
that's what I try to do and and what I
try to be objective
sometimes I've angered my own side
sometimes I criticize my own side or the
conservative government for example and
but not okay like if you have to tell
the truth you just have to tell the
truth so just to be clear for anyone who
may have not followed that necessarily
in its entirety what you're saying is
you were at the protest and your opinion
is that most of the violence was
instigated by the BLM associated groups
rather then because with the pictures
that I saw and I don't know what
happened I wasn't there but my
impression was you had these football
hooligan games who were attacking the
PAS morning throwing stuff at them no I
- salutes as Welli Nazi salute right
that apparently had well though that
that didn't I mean firstly the I didn't
see it and also the videos that they
said these are cities they were just
like little like football fans that do
the kind of like this and and they're
the videos on Twitter that people shares
and these are not still is that Gary
Lineker who is in football he knows
exactly what it is that's where you got
a taxing do you know that's not a notice
of it but obviously there were people
who would do that I'm not saying they
weren't I would definitely be some
people he we should leave in that and
and I'm not saying that the majority of
the black lives matter activists cause
violence they were largely peaceful yeah
oh yeah I mean generally was I mean well
peaceful in the sense that they were
still calls and care so still shouting
they still throwing
yeah sure yeah and and but the majority
of the violence happen from it being on
site that's the yeah that's different
yeah that's interesting so why do you
think anyone who was reading the
newspapers or watching the news would
have got a different impression so some
people say the media are purposefully
biased and some people would go like
with actual conspiracy theories that you
know oh there are obviously funded by
like you know obviously Marxists and I
mean if I find evidence I'll be fine but
I'll go with the fact that they are
asked completely out of touch the
mainstream media these organizations but
there's the BBC or anyway like even sky
they are very very proactive when it
comes to diversity of you know
finding staff members who are like in a
different skin color or different
genders but that in terms of the
diversity of thoughts or actual values
they're all the same they've all gone to
Oxbridge they've all wants the same
schools of all obviously like you know
the private schools in boarding school
they've all had the same kind of kind of
groups and they will believe in the same
things which is you know essentially big
government the control freaks like
nananana state and it's it's difficult
to be impartial if everybody in the
organization believe in the same thing
and this is what I'm kind of against
actually the the concept of completely
impartial news I would rather have news
outlets who are open about their biases
of what they are and like left-right
up-down and everything and people could
obviously decide for themselves you can
still have a concept like the BBC but if
they are if they become completely dry
and just report very boring just give
out the stats like fact-check or
whatever and those no one watch it
because it's a problem but Maya don't
you also think as well it's that because
our media is very left-leaning isn't it
sort of career death or suicide to come
out and go well I don't really agree
with the battlers matter organisation or
I don't really agree with the way they
conducted themselves all there were acts
of violence and thuggery on this
particular side yeah so this is exactly
what happens not as with the media with
brands right now companies the so-called
capitalist companies like Netflix and
well primarily in sky and they seem to
be afraid like the media that their
audience the audience on this planet or
in the West are generally liberal left
that's not the reality and again it's
because we've been brainwashed by that's
at education and media thinking for
example the whole country is like London
London is not the UK firstly it's not
the representative of the UK like New
York is not representative of America
but this is all you see and it's like
you know when you watch Hollywood movies
like that American movies that
everything's the same but when you go to
actual America deep America people don't
look like that people don't live like
that and it is gonna backfire my point
is for
example if Netflix are censoring their
own stuff if sky are primarily becoming
really woke like their audience of
football lads like even they are gonna
like lose revenue they're gonna lose
their supporters and it's happened with
Gillette last year when they did this
woke adverts for their product and they
lost a lot revenue and ironically
they're supporting black lives matter
whose agenda is to bring down capitalism
so the first people they go off there is
the same companies it's weird and when
you were there and you with the
protesters didn't a lot of them I
imagine a lot of them were just you know
kids young people you know who wanted to
make a difference all very very noble
but they didn't really understand what
BLM is all their political goals now I
would say than if I should say about my
sister she's 17 and she's currently one
of their supporters like in terms of the
course yeah and so this is that it's all
the other thing so there's the BLM
organization there's also the movement
and then there's the cause people forget
about the actual that there are three so
some people say I believe the movement
and I don't even believe in the movement
because the organization the agenda
whether you like it on is communist
that's that's what it is the movement is
about identity politics and the cause
anti racism well we should all be
anti-racist I believe in that that's
fine and I will fight racism if I see
case by case you know whatever and I
don't believe that there is
institutional racism in this country
that's them but what the movement tells
you and yeah there are a lot of people
who especially young kids where they're
you know that's well that's what they're
fed and you know if a police officer in
America is brutal against someone well
it's definitely because that put that
police officer is racist but did you
read his mind
obviously there are individual racist
police officers but you know first you
need evidence because they're data that
came out that the police officers in
America killed back in 2018 killed nine
unarmed black people but also 19
unarmed white people so that's just one
piece of data and there was also other
data that should to prove that there's a
problem with police brutality not
necessarily they're all racist or they
have a racist guidelines and they just
go after black people doesn't it's not
true
I think another question that and I'm by
the way I really appreciate what you've
separated the moon
the organization and the cause and the
cause I think that's a really good thing
and that makes a lot of sense because
everybody supports the cause everybody
supports ending racism while preventing
racism from happening but I and I think
a lot of people don't want to go down
that intellectual route you're finding
out what the cause and we but it's not
just to me I think it's I think it's
more than that I think I found myself
saying to people okay you say you
support black lives matter and I support
being against racism I completely
support that but have you had a look at
what the organization there actually
stands for and they go no send me the
link so I send them the link and then I
don't hear back yep and I think part of
that is if you are given that
information yeah and you ingest it and
you are intellectually honest then you
go well I know I can't support this
therefore I no longer support black
lives matter oh and then people don't
don't want to go down that road it's
true and then you find out you're
Russian exactly exactly
you people just I think a lot of people
are just terrified it's also the falls
of both sides I don't officially the
both sides at the all sides on every
political debate because because humans
are tribal and it's literally like
supporting a football club when it calls
a political cause for some reason
whereas liking it for example brexit as
a topic was supposed to be quite well
dry and boring it's the concept of
brexit is supposed to be who do you want
to do your paperwork the building in
Westminster or the building in Brussels
these admins it's a very bureaucratic
thing I obviously became more
interesting and sexy so people took
sighs like football teams same thing
with this the problem is both sides
whether you answer your problm as an
organization - outta each other so if
you had someone coming to you problm
saying it can you like what prove to me
that I'm wrong
usually you would say as an anti PLM but
let's just say that person would say
well I suppose you're commies that
wouldn't help mm-hmm you know if you're
kind of slightly more civilized and be
like no this is this is the fact just
I'll leave it to you like just whatever
and if they come back then you could
shout but you're me like I used to look
comedy video I literally gave me the
information and and I think this is the
problem by the cause I mean even the
movement is idiotic it's like going on
the street and say the skies
oh well done Oh like I like people like
babies oh yeah we all did
but the thing I was gonna ask and it's
it's Khedive explain it the thing I was
gonna ask about it is and it's a
question that I haven't heard anyone ask
or anyone explained the answer to is why
do you think we're having these protests
in this country about something that
happened in America but I don't know why
are people in Brazil
protesting about this why are people
protesting all around the world about
this one incident that happened in the
United States why why is it that we do
that it's because they're so people
think is lazy as our America does
exports things to us but like Halloween
and everything but it's not just that
it's the same reason that when for
example someone a clump became president
you had massive protests in London hmm
whereas if when the president G became
president in China he didn't have any
protests because and so if I were to
like put myself in the shoes of the left
they think that they have high standards
of the West they have high expectations
from and the West and this is
surprisingly ironically kind of races
because they're putting Americans and
the Brits in his same category because
he looked the same and you have the same
language so you're the same and
surprisingly Americans are very
different to Europeans and so if they
look different Americans like as a as a
in terms of the masses this skin color
and also had different language I don't
think you could they could have said
that it's because they generally look
white and they speak English they put us
in the same category and every single
then there's the debate in America we
get stuck in it as well and it's not
just us in Canada and obviously certain
other countries Scandinavia sometimes
whereas you're right if something if
people read it's like extension
rebellion with environments you know we
are doing really well in this country in
terms of you know the being
pro-environmental whether you like I
don't know that's what the government's
gender is they're doing it really well
everything's very clean and green there
are problems in Asia India and China go
there but you know they don't do that
and do you think Meyer that what the BLM
protested is that expose that we have
weak leadership in this country
particularly with Boris Johnson because
I didn't see him
make a stand for a long long time when
everything was kicking off yeah I mean
with the short-term problems of like you
know letting these here basically
anarchists go around and do whatever
they want
absolutely weak leadership and the
Boris's government the whole cabinet
Downing Street have been very late to
everything recently mmm every decision
been late even with the lockdown to come
a distance light if they're gonna do it
or not and then we did school like can
you go back to schools no we want okay
look just lead aside everything was like
this and I think they especially ever
since he came back from hospital hasn't
been himself but that's one issue
there's there has been weak leadership
in the West when it comes to tackling
these things but this is the recent one
we've had things like this before again
you had the Anika green people in a
protesting before and just did a lot of
things they shut down the City Airport
in London but I think that the the
weakness the biggest weakness we have
his intellectual weakness and again he
conflicted overnight we could use
generation over generation to do it but
we can't because education system is and
academia is dominated by the liberal
left and people are right wing usually
either don't want to be teachers I just
want to live their own life and make
money or whatever and and or they get
ousted then they get kicked out see the
thing is I I know that there's someone
who's a conservative you're coming at it
from that kind of a level of right
versus left
I actually don't necessarily see it that
way I think what's happened in academia
is the far left have squeezed everyone
else out so it's not a quite a question
of the right fighting the left in
universities I think what it's a
question of is everyone being squeezed
out by a crazy fringe that I don't think
you know we we have many people from the
left on the show people like Paul Embry
the socialist Labor Party lifetime
member et cetera who has nothing in
common with these people and I think
that's really the issue that people are
gonna have to confront is it's not in
the interest of the left to be
represented by these people is it yeah
the thing I mean you just made a good
point a yeah so to clarify when I talk
about the left I am actually yes talking
about the hard left and and that's the
problem you just points out the problem
even if I someone like me says the left
I'm basically generalizing than all of
them
right and the racist absolutely yes but
but yeah because the rest of the left of
the center which I don't believe in
center but the moderate left or the
Liberals and yeah their problem that the
problem I have with them is they're all
big government control freaks and but
and and but yet the actual hardener
which is a very more intellectual side
and but also becomes very violent like
an intellectually violent is that what
what does I mean intellectually violent
so they are exactly the opposite of my
philosophy which is as I said I'm a
humanized I I believe in everything
saying every single thing we should do
every policy every direction politics
should be towards humanity and not in a
sense of compassion that's the problem
we have people on the left
well actually general left have the
platform of compassion and good
intentions and say because we care about
humans we should take money from that
person or give it to someone else and
like no no they're the values of basic
values of humanity which is freedom
don't tell people to do no coercion and
opportunity and justice just go with
those values and every single thing that
we do every policy should be to make
sure you're not taking anyone's freedom
you're making sure that no one's getting
harmed by someone else and just let them
be opportunities there to do whatever
they want to do and whereas the when I
said there are intellectually violent is
they are essentially every single idea
that they have ironically even though
there is there to help people they think
they are there to help people but it's
actually very very anti human and anti
human instincts and that's the problem
with the Marxism or near cultural
Marxist and what are we going to call it
that they that supposedly they're
supposed to be coming up with all these
ideas to help humanity but they become
so tribal that they're not defending
humans anymore they're defending their
ideology and my you said that you don't
believe in the center now Constantine
described himself as a centrist can you
explain to him and no 300 words or less
why he's wrong please yeah it's like
bisexuals just
it's like people who makes tea and
coffee together no no I get the concept
of why people secret as I said the way I
describe myself and it's a bit of a
pick-and-mix whole thing so yes it's
more of a I would change the word
centered we pick a mix because you can't
be a Puritan conservative or peers and
liberal or socialist and I don't think
they exist some some exist and the it's
intolerable because yes you could be you
know culturally conservative but in a
socially liberal or whatever so people
think that's the center by a centum I
don't mean people who have beliefs that
are in a sense I'm talking about like
political parties or the agent yeah it's
not an ideology is not if you stop
trying to make the center gun doesn't
exist no it's black hole no I agree with
you like what I mean when I say I'm in
the center is that I have some
conservative policies that you use have
some liberal views it's just a mixture
of the two and therefore I don't feel
like I'm part of the center right or the
center left it's just this resistor [ __ ]
you welcome to the last episode of
trigonometry but we always talk about
you know going back to racing that we
live in a deeply racist country and you
know and it's propagated by people on
the left and you know you're somebody
who came to this country as an immigrant
emphasis country from Iran do you think
we have a problem of racism in this
country do we think this is a racist
nation yeah I had experienced massive
racism in erupt but not for me but I've
seen other people who yeah yeah so I
could play the card and I hate to play
the card kid I don't understand just to
prove it prove my point that the
personal card because I don't like you
when people say well I experienced this
that means that's basically the reality
but from personal perspective we came
here our family genuinely have an
experience the racism in that sense of
experience racist comments ironically
from the left people people calling me
Uncle Tom or whatever and whereas I have
cousins in Germany who every now and
then they get beaten up in alleyways
just because they're brown just casual I
can and it used to it's like a Tuesday
like I walk in alleyways like your
office up there
go home oh yeah got pinned up against ya
genuinely it's so there is and it is the
journey that is now supposed to be
self-hating and progressive so it still
happens and again you use are the
constants and cultures in Asia in Africa
and North Africa especially and but I
don't think you could find anybody would
be able to give you actual evidence even
it by evidence I mean like actually like
recordings or like Ana just use their
phone to for example over a period of a
month and they're out there someone
who's not white to give you Oh I
experienced like 55 examples of racism
in that sense like in a constantly
doesn't exist it won't happen also by
racist society I'm talking about
institutional racism and politicians
people in charge
it is absolutely especially with the
British culture because they were
exposed to other cultures because of the
Empire and did and there was a reason
that after that the Commonwealth was
created they all wanted to come to the
UK from Nigeria in India despite the
problems that passed whereas all the
other colonies for other countries in
Europe didn't really want to go to like
you know like Spain or Portugal they all
stayed in like you know obviously South
America or whatever and I think it yeah
the British culture war is because it's
as we said more tolerant and just
slightly nicer because they have to be
polite because they can't be mean and
racist to you directly
so you I can assure you you won't
experience racism as much in this
country at some point so I guess what
you're saying is there are people who
may be raised of course the time to time
but it's not likely that the experience
of an ethnic minority person is the day
to day they experience this oppressive
just a wall of mistreatment and not just
that I did that and there's sort of
things that the English let's just say
the actual English that people go with
the English identity get accused of like
racism you know and it'll breaks it
stuff you keep whatever and I have
spoken to a lot of these people and
we're talking about like ordinary people
who like you know just getting both with
politics or go on the street or whatever
they get accused of being racist but in
reality they're tribalist aids they they
defend you know Britain and the border
and they are
foreigners are coming in here taking the
jobs or whatever but when you actually
talk to them and try to have a slightly
semi intellectual conversation with them
when you sit down you realize it's not
the skin color or anything else it's the
whole tribal thing that you know we need
to protect our community we need to
protect our country we're not saying
don't come in we just don't want it like
in a I'm in a village like ten people
and then now we have eleven new people
because the tribalism that I've
experienced these conversations from
like people in Cornwall people in
Lincolnshire they also hated people
coming from London so it's not the skin
colour did they hate other white British
people to come into their communities
and like taking their jobs as it's not
less its tribalism that's the problem we
have in this country yeah well and again
I'm whether you are gonna be able to
eradicate that from human nature I don't
know that you can no that's the thing
when the movement of BLM think that we
have to well eliminate racism and
Prejudice right it's like saying there
shouldn't be any bad firstly there needs
to be bad for you to recognize what's
good there's black and white no pun
intended but but it generates the you
could minimize by creating society
that's more progressive and less used to
use education and we are doing it ready
the progress we've made over the past
century over the past few decades they
don't get it it's the same with
socialists who are anti-capitalist who
are saying oh because we have homeless
people we have poor people give up
compared to like a few decades ago and
you know we're getting there but there
everybody's in a rush they want instant
change and the moment they tried to fix
it they're going to create more problems
yes yeah I mean it's very very
interesting that you say that I mean
where do you see as culturally do you
think we've hit a crisis point now
between you know because you said that
we were making great progress in I've
seen Society over the last few years
with the you know the digestion of
identity politics become more racialized
become we now like to put people into
these wonderful little subgroups and do
you think we've hit crisis point you
when it comes to the culture wars or do
you think it's going to get worse and
it's not the peak yet but doesn't mean
that it will get to the peak in time
that you would like
be like 1984 we could but it could also
go back down not quickly and not that
easily so the two obvious options will
either be scenarios you are they gonna
you could actually get to a point in the
next few decades that we will have a
1984 Society a Big Brother Society this
time ironically not created by the state
of government but by society itself the
mob mentality and that's a problem and
this is the issue we have inserted
cultures
certain cultures in like the Middle East
like Saudi Arabia it's not just the fact
that the state is also a Syrian
but societies authoritarians like anti
women's rights and everything but
actually before you go on here and I
really want you to finish that point I
mean you talk about how it would be the
people I mean the people are gonna find
some voice some left-wing authoritarian
is gonna come along and say look in the
interest of inclusion and diversity yeah
people aren't gonna be allowed to say
what they think anymore yeah and I'm the
I'm the man or the woman or the whatever
yep to make that happen for you and and
and if there's an electorate that wants
that they'll bow for that yes so this is
my point so you will either we will
either find a way in the next couple of
decades they did next two generations
basically to become slightly more sound
and fight back
things will get STEMI bad we might
actually have comedy be canceled
I would still have some freedoms but
things like this people fight back or
yes I know it's like massive
exaggeration people don't see it because
we're so complacent we take everything
for granted we've been in the West for
century being good we've had freedom but
nothing lasts forever mmm even the Roman
Empire didn't last forever so I'm not
saying it to be pessimistic or scare
monger anybody but we take could come a
time maybe in a century maybe a lot less
that the West will be completely changed
and will be dictatorial and then I think
you're gonna have situation where people
are gonna have to just wake up and rise
up again but then hopefully I won't be a
lot of ways I don't think any of us are
gonna be alive at that point I'd wonder
whether you're right and I also wonder
whether decades is the right timeframe
well we need to fight now and that's
that's what I do on my YouTube and
that's what everybody should do
comedians
again brands companies they should be
basically a new Netflix to fight against
Netflix if they want to become woke like
we should always do this start now
well it's interesting I mean what comedy
for example there's already talk of like
a non-work comedy platform being created
and they will be funny probably will be
very funny yeah yeah but it's difficult
for example you talk about being a
libertarian this may be an issue that we
should discuss with you as well is well
what what's your take on big tech the
censorship that we see from them and
equally what's the solution there
because you know Twitter is quite
clearly biased is not an objective
platform on the one hand on the other
hand they've created this new parlor
thing yep which I've joined just just
because everyone's telling me to and I
don't want to be in that parlor world
either because it's it's very much the
same but from another angle
it's just people from the right and I'm
not really that interested in being in
an echo chamber that's the problem at
I've heard it so many times on YouTube
people say you know we should we should
create a right wing YouTube and that or
like with parla because the current
platforms are biased towards the left
like well two wrongs don't make it right
right and so either libertarian so I I
believe private businesses should do
whatever they want to do but also as
consumers because criticize them and and
we could leave them we could join them
we could do whatever we want and I don't
believe we have with people who are
worried about monopolies for example and
you we haven't had luckily my that my
side of the economic philosophy is who
is right on this he might change and we
haven't had an example in the West or in
the world there to have a monopoly in
any industry especially long term
monopolies that has been under a free
society every monopoly we've had like
back in the sixties and seventies in the
West in America and other places here
with oil and and then 80s and onwards it
banking is always because there was
government invention and it was always
backfiring because government got
involved to make sure there's no
monopoly and they'd actually created
monopolies and now in this country with
the energy sector the government got
involved with the labor party and we had
like 14 companies now we have six
companies so
the best way to make sure that we don't
have a monopoly like Twitter what about
Facebook is luckily tech is still set
relatively relatively free because the
internet is difficult to regulate so
there was a time when people thought
Facebook was it like you know and if
we're not gonna have any new platforms
and Facebook could become really boring
or Facebook could destroy us and we have
nowhere else to go but then obviously
Instagram came I know is still linked
Facebook but they can tell us of
platforms and Twitter YouTube we have
and everything else I'm parlor and but
you don't think Google and YouTube are
monopolies in their fields with it so it
depends how you define monopolies they
are big players but by monopoly I'm
talking about the absolute monopoly
which is like you know there's one
website okay yeah but let me let me put
it kind of bluntly for you if YouTube
and you tomorrow
yep is there a place where you could go
that you would be able to continue to do
what you I know the answer is fortune
this is my point right is they could
destroy you in a moment's notice and
there's nothing you can do about it you
probably wouldn't even able to get the
information to people out there that
it's happened in a big way yes well I
would go to what's that new fan only fan
[Laughter]
your stuff up on there say it's on the
one and again as a libertarian I would
say I could create my own website and
have a podcast like a video podcast and
mhm and take donations or whatever I'll
sell my merchandise and but yes I will
get I'll get a hit I'll take a hit until
the revenue yeah ninety-nine percent
yeah no yeah that's so but I'm fine with
it because if YouTube wants to kick me
out is their business you know it's like
you know people who are trying to force
their bakeries to bake gay cakes or
whatever I'm not religious you know it's
their right if they don't want to do it
and and and they could have their own
again under the freedom of religion
especially in the West in America as
well so we still have that so you can
also protect that even though I'm not
actually religious it really just in
that sense
but Maya Dyson they've got simply got
too much power
youtubers simply too powerful they're
too big yeah so actually we need
somebody to come in and break them up
otherwise what we're gonna have is well
it's good to glorify monopolies isn't it
on my own I'm wrong
boy it is it is it is monopolies in that
sense obviously and it's the biggest
player and but the moment you try to get
and win say someone if by someone you
mean a government or politician or a
bureaucrat that's never worked in
history of humanity yeah again this is
the problem I have with the different
political ideologies because people
usually go with the politics of
intention rather than outcome and you
know if we go with intention we all want
the same things we want to eliminate
poverty we want everyone to be safe and
healthy and you know well often know
monopolies everybody wants the same
things same good thing with hope BLM
stuff everybody's anti-racist but go
with the intention and go with evidence
and unfortunately it's not a sexy topic
to talk about and like especially when
it comes to economics so because now I
have to say because I come from the like
Australian Australian School of
Economics which is kind of very
libertarian and like Hayek and ourside
always struggled intellectually to
defend or promote our values because
it's not sexy it's like and let's let's
have this platform free free
transactions but trust me is gonna work
like well how long do off the way well
ten years ten minutes where is there
that the other side where's the
Keynesianism
or liberal or socialist or whatever yeah
they say the don't worry about the
outcome but this is what we wanted you
this is the goal you know and then no
one actually cares about the outcomes
law could effort you know work but good
effort will support you that's a book
well this is where I think I agree with
you very strongly but I also disagree
with you very strongly which is that
disagree with Francis in the stance
because I think you're completely wrong
about diagnosing the problem because if
YouTube were to ban you tomorrow they
have the power to destroy people who
don't agree with them and they will
start to use it in my opinion on the one
hand on the other hand I don't think
breaking them up is going to make it
better you know and I don't
and the real truth is I don't know what
would make it better and and so this is
the quite a dangerous situation because
what happens is as you say people start
going from intention and they start
flailing around and trying different
things they start let's break them up
let's revoke their publication privilege
if they if you do that they'll they'll
sense even more than they already do
right so I don't know what the solution
is but the problem needs to be addressed
and so we need to look for a solution
going just like Oh lawmen libertarian
let them do what they want I don't think
that's gonna Ono so I didn't so I didn't
say maybe I didn't say let's not do it
so what do we do yeah yeah I didn't see
if they kicked me out I'll be fine right
I can open
I'll definitely shout and all but the
solution has always been their humanity
humans always society will have to fight
back because you know we always live on
that they get instinct of survival hmm
and we almost went extinct a couple of
times there many since we were like
eight months so we always find a
solution especially when it comes to
free markers and economics supply and
demand if you should cross the line a
few times and and and the thing is with
these sort of things when when again
when humans start to do bad things like
a new censoring stuff for example it's
not just right-wingers are the comment
that eventually they kind of eat
themselves at the left like they going
after JK Rowling now and in it so when
when that happens when they actually
lose credibility then there will be
people who would actually leave the
platform enough of them and then free
market it will provide a new company
that company doesn't have to be
right-wing actually ideally shouldn't be
right shouldn't be you should just be
I'm here to make profit that's the
intention here's a new YouTube and that
will happen and it's always happen and
people will say well how would you know
it'll happen it's always happening with
every industry where there's food but
it's closed but there's transport planes
that was supposed to be monopoly but not
anymore and people always again like
taxis and uber now and then they've got
nuber web sites and apps and society
always provide Hartmann well as
reassuring when we get back all this
real estate man somebody will come along
and provide maybe it might be a Russian
state-funded platform that'd be great
when I think I'm sure you'll be very
very secure and no information would
leak anywhere whatsoever
boom AIA thanks for coming on we've got
one more question before we let you go
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society but we really
should be this is a difficult one
because what I would usually say is as
some of the things I've been ranting
throughout the whole video and let's
genuinely talk about where they would
talk about politics or behavior or our
culture let's focus on what is more
logical and rational in terms of go with
intent don't go with intention go with
outcome and I think we have to talk
about the one thing we have to start
talking about is academia and education
and we have to seriously look into
reforming it because we've been talking
about how to perform businesses these
platforms and brands and politicians
governments but not many people actually
talking about education they'll be
talking about how oh yeah there are
left-wing obviously but we have no
solution because I said for example I
don't like to see use the words
right-wingers but the anti left
don't become teachers don't get into the
education system and and then we wonder
why each generation is becoming more
bias than weird and avocado eating
Islington living that's the problem we
haven't I think we should really look
into academia in the West you're right
about that and we get so many messages
both Francis and I from teachers or
people in the education system who say
well though I I'm not right-wing but I'm
not super woke left-wing and I I feel
like a pariah in in in the staff room
yeah people won't talk to me
I fear speaking my mind because I've
seen what happens to other people who do
I think there's a lot of people who
watch this show who messages and say
literally that you know and I think
that's an issue I think that's an issue
that needs to be addressed
Maya thank you so much for coming on
where can people follow your work and
check out the stuff that you do yeah so
at youtube.com slash myattís t-wolves
basically my name is difficult to spell
base is my full name mah yr tou SI and
yeah hopefully you'll join and subscribe
get free t-shirts no it's not free the
paper is right-wing but my thanks for
coming on thank you thank you guys for
watching we'll see you very soon with an
episode or a live stream make sure you
tune in we have a live stream on Tuesday
Thursday Friday and Saturday as well as
the two TVs that we put out online
business Sundays
absolutely and all our episodes all our
live streams go out at 7 p.m. UK time 7
p.m. UK time we'll see you there
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell buttons next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media at trigger pot and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
spread the word